Speaker 1: Welcome to the David Pakman
show. I am Ferron Cousins from Ring of Fire,
sitting in once again today for David Pakman.
We've got a wonderful show coming up for you
today. Jim Jordan is being sued by Alvin Bragg.
Melania Trump is furious at the media for talking
about all of her marriage problems. Dianne
Feinstein is facing more and more calls to
resign after it was revealed that she has missed
more than 60 votes this year. And, of course,
all the legal problems with Donald Trump. All of
that and more is coming up on today's program. So
let's jump right into it. Alvin Bragg, Manhattan
district attorney, has announced that he is suing
Republican Representative Jim Jordan and pretty
much the House Judiciary Committee trying to stop
a subpoena that Jordan issued last week. For Mark
Pomeranz. Now, I had already thought that the idea
to subpoena Mark Pomeranz by Jim Jordan was very
dumb. If you're not familiar with Mark Pomeranz,
he is one of the two former assistant
prosecutors at the Manhattan DA's office,
along with Kerry Dunn. They worked under Cyrus
Vance on the Trump investigation and Pomeranz and
Dunn resigned last year. And Pomeranz has revealed
since then in both his resignation letter and his
new book that he resigned because when Alvin Bragg
took over from Cy Vance, he pretty much killed the
investigation into Donald Trump. Pomeranz has gone
as far as to say that he and Vance actually had
the indictments drafted against Donald Trump.
He said they were less than ten days away from
charging Donald Trump with financial crimes. And
then Brad came in, put that investigation on ice,
and the rest is history, right? Well, Jim Jordan,
for some reason thought it would be a smart idea
to bring Pomeranz into the House Judiciary
Committee to testify because he thought
Pomeranz his testimony would somehow prove
that Alvin Bragg had actually weaponized.
The Manhattan DA's office to go after Trump
and he weaponized it to go after Trump by
not going after Trump, according to the guy
Jim Jordan wants to talk to in the House. So
if it's a little confusing, don't worry. It's very
confusing. Jim Jordan's strategy here makes no
sense at all. Pomeranz is not going to waltz into
the House Judiciary Committee and say, Oh yeah,
Alvin Bragg Absolutely weaponize this. No, he is
going to say, based on what he's already said,
that Alvin Bragg should have gone harder
after Donald Trump, and then he's going
to start laying out all the evidence they had
against Donald Trump with the financial crimes.
So if Pomeranz goes to that Judiciary Committee
hearing, it's going to make Jim Jordan look even
dumber than he already has this year. I think
that's a good thing. I want that to happen.
But I can understand why Alvin Bragg doesn't. And
that, of course, is why Alvin Bragg is suing to
stop this subpoena from happening. And honestly,
legally speaking, he has very strong grounds under
which to challenge this subpoena. He can easily
say that, obviously, because these are ongoing
investigations, they have not been closed.
We, under New York state law, are forbidden
from turning over evidence, from turning over
documents related to ongoing investigations
to third parties. And at this point, because
Congress does not directly oversee the Manhattan
DA's office, they would be considered a third
party. It'd be no different than handing over
the information that they've gathered to Fox News.
That's kind of how Congress is for the Manhattan
DA's office. You're just an independent
third party. Sure, you've got some power,
but you have no power here. So he has very
strong legal grounds under which to challenge
this subpoena. But I kind of wish he wouldn't.
I really, really, really want Mark Pomerantz to
waltz into that chamber and spill the beans on
all of the horrible evidence that they uncovered
in their Trump investigation. That is what I want
to see. And I think a lot of people probably want
to see that as well. If we're going to air some
dirty laundry, let's air it out. Let's put it all
out there on the line for the world to see,
because that's what Jim Jordan wants to do.
And I think in this particular instance, we need
to honor Jim Jordan's request. We need to give
him exactly what he wants. Because I believe, as
Oscar Wilde has said, you know, there's two great
tragedies in life. One is not getting what you
want. The other is getting exactly what you want.
So let's give Jim Jordan exactly what
he wants. Let's give him Marc Pomerantz,
his testimony about the investigations into Donald
Trump. Let's let the entire country hear what Mark
Pomerantz has to say about all of that evidence,
about the indictments that they had drafted
and about why those indictments didn't get filed.
Let's hear it from him. But that's not what Jim
Jordan wants to hear. It's what he would hear,
but it's not what he wants to hear. He wants to
hear. Pomeranz Go in there and whine and cry
and say, Oh, Alvin Bragg made us look at this
stuff and we didn't want to. We knew it was phony
baloney. But yeah, that ain't going to happen.
But flip side of the coin, as I said, I
understand why Bragg doesn't want this to happen.
If Pomeranz were to go into a Judiciary
Committee hearing and start saying that
Bragg was a weak prosecutor, we had all this
strong evidence. He chose not to do it. It's
going to make Bragg look bad, and then you're
going to have people on the left as well as
all of the freaks on the right hating on Alvin
Bragg. And that's not what we need right now.
I am still annoyed. I'm still angry that Alvin
Bragg did not go after Donald Trump for the big
financial crimes that Pomerantz and Don and Vance
were all investigating and ready to indict him
for. I think that was a mistake. I think that
was a giant misstep based on the statements
that Pomerantz has already made publicly. It
seems very clear that they had Donald Trump
red handed in a lot of these instances. Now,
that would have been up for a jury to decide.
But now a jury is not even going to get the
opportunity to decide that. And that's not fair.
If the indictments were ready, as Pomerantz
says they were, they should have been filed.
Bragg didn't want to go that route. Bragg went the
route he did. He got his indictments, you know,
34 counts against Donald Trump. Trial coming up
probably in about a year. So it all worked itself
out. But Bragg doesn't want Pomerantz to talk.
And again, I understand why and I understand
there's laws in New York that would likely
prevent Pomerantz from saying the things that
I want to hear him say. But. Bragg has the law
on his side. Jim Jordan only has politicization,
the weaponization of the weaponization committee.
And maybe he wins. Maybe he doesn't. We'll see
what happens. As this lawsuit that Bragg has
filed plays itself out in the court system